hey bread we've got this been preparing
you've done your power poses you got
your Blue Bottle coffee just don't spill
it on Marc Benioff for you hi everyone I
am Brad hunger Minh I am a new product
manager here at Salesforce and I'm just
really excited today to be talking to
you about some of the different customer
features that we've been studying for
the last the last few months we came up
with some really good ideas that I want
to share with you and so let me just
throw a couple of stats up on the board
for you schedule I don't know why isn't
why is he so nervous I there we go well
well I can't remember the exact
statistics but the really important
thing I want you did we're definitely up
so I want to ask you what did Brad do
wrong here
anyone Stephanie you got it right he was
very nervous and it really showed his
body language was all off he was
touching his neck in his hair which
signifies nervousness he was holding a
cup in front of him which puts a
physical barrier between him and his
audience and he was just not doing well
so today we're going to talk to you
about how to rock your next presentation
with body language the agenda for today
is taught and explaining to you why body
language is crucial for your next
presentation given you four tips of body
language you can use and then telling
you a story about an entrepreneur who
use body language to build his business
now we're all in this class and we think
and we've got we become better
presenters but we but we don't know
so ninety-three percent of communication
is nonverbal and that's why it's so
important and fifty percent of it is
actually body language alone and all of
you will present in your next job you
might think you might be able to wiggle
out of it but that's not true
Stephanie you're going into growth
equity so you're going to present
investment opportunities to your
partners Reid you're going into
consulting you'll need to present to
clients as a way to move up in your
organization we're all have to do it now
I want you to turn off your brains and
turn to parts on because we're going to
talk about statistics seventy percent of
Americans believe that presentation
skills are crucial for career success
and senior exec when senior executives
have been surveyed in the past they said
that executive presence accounts for
twenty six percent of what it takes to
get promoted to the next level that's a
fourth of what it takes to get promoted
I'm not sure how much performance
actually is so maybe Jeff Pfeffer was
right after all
so now I'm going to turn it over to Paul
who will give you some tips on body
language we've spent all week in the
acronym Factory we've thought about lots
of permutations of letters and we've
come up with four that you need to
remember for you to walk out of this
room a better nonverbal communicator my
friends I present today the awesome it's
gonna require a little bit of memory on
your part because a stands for approach
your audience with an eyebrow flash
but this is actually really serious and
I was stunned when I did the research
that the top half of your face is seen
as being more authentic than the bottom
half of your face people perceive that
the area around your mouth is easily
manipulable and that what you're doing
with your mouth isn't necessarily
trustworthy when you emot-- with the top
of your face when you raise your
eyebrows when you show interest when you
light up your eyes people feel a
connection coming out of that they feel
closer to you and they feel more of an
engagement with your content so when you
walk into a room to give a presentation
some of the tips we've learned earlier
in the class are important to pause scan
the room don't rush into whatever you're
saying but also raise your eyes engage
with your audience and use the top half
of your face in this way the next part
of the awesome framework it doesn't have
to be by the way a Jim Carrey eyebrow
the next part of the awesome framework
is to win with the right smile and this
is really important because smiling is
contagious when you smile like Nisha is
right now it makes the rest of the room
happier it makes people more engaged and
it makes people feel more confident in
what you're saying
smiling especially when you smile
authentically and not a kind of force
teeth grin smiling gives you more
confidence in what you're saying it
releases endorphins in your body that
makes you feel stronger makes you feel
more confident makes you feel more
powerful walk into a room
pause scan the room raise your eyes
smile it's all going to help you connect
better with your audience build more
confidence in your presentation and
ultimately get the results that you're
hoping for Brad's got the next two parts
of the awesome framework
now Paul is just shared with you a
couple of important techniques to make
sure that your facial expressions are
really demonstrating the confidence and
competence that you want to convey in
your next big presentation what I want
to do is I'm going to switch gears and
talk about the lower parts of your body
and know how to use them effectively as
well starting with your hands now the
next part in our awesome framework is s
steepling with confidence just like
Angela here she does a pretty good job
of it but you don't want to look like on
glaze right now permanently with your
hand steeple I don't know if you all
noticed it but Leo in the presentation
just a few minutes ago was steepling
like a pro did it just enough to look
confident and two-point emphasis on his
points and that's exactly what you want
to use sealing for you don't want to
just do it for the sake of doing it do
with the purpose and so just do it
sparingly now when you're not steepling
you have a few other techniques that you
can draw from as well and they all have
to do with open ha open palm gestures
okay you might not want to do exactly
that because that looks a little
defensive and this looks like you're
asking for something but this is another
way to demonstrate emphasis and
confidence without the aggression of
pointing at someone one of my bad habits
now you can also double it up and use
two hands to double your emphasis both
good techniques and lastly the M in our
awesome framework stands for moving to
keep your audience's attention or if you
can't remember that moving like JD does
in his presentations so there's really
two techniques that you're going to want
to remember when to move forward and
when to move back when you're moving
forward that's when you're going to want
to emphasize a point and GQ I might even
couple it up with some si point to
really emphasize my
but when I'm done talking with you I'm
going to break and pause and move back
and that's going to be a natural change
to a different topic how many of you
heard about this the humans of New York
so I don't have to explain this is
Brandon Stanton the end guy in the cap
what he does is every day morning he
takes his camera and he walks up to a
stranger and then asked his permission
his or her permission to take the
photograph and then engages in a
conversation with that person let's for
a moment assume that you're all
strangers here and then Brandon Stanton
I walk like this
look at the strangers and take out the
camera now suppose you might say did a
programmer this is the challenge what
Brandon faces everyday in a split second
he has to build the trust and confidence
with a stranger first to get the consent
to take the photograph second to engage
in the conversation that actually builds
a story for him and he has done tens and
thousands of these interviews and he is
experimented with multiple things the
script for example using the word
photograph versus using the word
portrayed 100 times he has done it but
the interesting conclusion that he has
come to is that the script doesn't
matter all that matters is the body
language the trust and the relaxation
and the confidence that you convey in
the body language is it is that matters
at the end of it so this is a great
story and we spoke about body language
today we heard about axon bias we heard
about talking in the second language so
if you think those biases exist use the
body language aids and we give you a
great model today the awesome model
so with that we're all going to come out
and we'd love to take some questions and
talk to you more about nonverbal
communication and how we can all be pros
at it